eight or nine years ago uh before I had
ever spoken at esselen or anywhere for
that matter
can't described me once as somebody who
wants to rule the world without leaving
their own living room
so what
but I really believe that the best idea
will win and that the obligation
incumbent upon every one of us is to
just give it your best shot and when I
hear a winning idea in any field I feel
like I just have a real nose for it and
it's a wonderful feeling to recognize
you know people like William Gibson Tom
Robbins in another dimension Rupert
sheldrake Ralph Abraham
rihannaisler
wonderful men and women who
really love truth and who feel like a
fraternity and the edges are fuzzly
defined new people are coming in every
single one of you brings tremendous
richness to this process I mean we
really learn a great deal I I really
almost see myself as a coordinator of
information I mean a networker not among
people but among ideas and schools and
pieces of information you just bring it
together and put it to put it back and
this is how this cohesion arises this is
how we lose the fear of each other that
makes the ego possible and how we lose
the fear of the future that makes
political Solutions impossible I mean we
just have to get to know ourselves and
each other and as this process moves
forward I think all barriers will fall
for us this is not the
moment of what has been a glorious
experiment now gone awry this is in fact
the last moments before real
civilization and we're about to move out
of the Neolithic and into a broader
Horizon of human becoming that will
unite our aspirations and our hopes with
the energy of imagination and we will
you know create and experience and
become on a scale that we can very dimly
imagine we are involved in
redefining for the entire universe what
is possible
stretching the envelope every work of
art every yet clearer statement of how
it is stretches uh the size and the
limits of the entire universe we are
informative in this tremendous Cosmic
process that is going on around us we
are not Spectators we are in fact
somehow centrally spun in to the plot
and anticipating the way in which we're
spun into the plot and what the denuma
shall be is I think the great
intellectual adventure of Post history